deux lacs sandales accent mais après
tout en neige pourquoi cette faveur
pourquoi ce privilège
et si je vous disais après tout jean ce
du nord que c'est vous qui pour nous
semblait l'avoir très fort bien sûr
monsieur fernand belle c'est moi qui ai
l'accent d'écouter ma voix elle ne
chante pas n'exagère pas elle est
normale et quoi ici je vous disais que
c'est vous monsieur fernandel qui avait
l'accent l'accent c'est l'autre mais qui
a l'accent moi vous où ai je dit qu'ils
[Musique]
passent des jours la dacia fier de
l'être et veut le rester
enfin toujours pour dire que photo
jaureguiberry champions
à
[Musique]
en
pendant des mois j'ai sillonné la france
marseillais
alsatia parisiens ou picard kelly le bon
accent
j'ai rencontré romain kevin sonia et
yoann ils ont 20 ans et leur accent 10
en sont fiers pourtant parfois il leur
arrive de le dissimuler
moi je trouve ça beau d'avoir un accent
partie de moi même et fait capable de
pouvoir ressortir ma copine avec qui je
suis depuis maintenant un petit rhône
quand même au début m'a dit ce qu on te
voit on a misé par la victoire et quand
ouvre la bouche on ne put écouté et j'ai
bien compris que les gens autour et elle
se disait lui voilà il vient de
il vient débauche ça s'entend est ce que
je peux dire que c'est un handicap
peut-être je crois que c'est un handicap
de 4 l'accent est il vraiment un
handicap et que cela veut-il dire sur
notre langage
mon enquête commence à quelques pas du
vieux-port yoann et sonia veulent
devenir comédien et au théâtre le
message est clair prière de déposer son
accent à l'entrée ensuite on va
travailler sur le son en est sûre le
sont 1
la corse est pas un c'est un et en on va
commencer avec yoann papa poids dans les
pins pas papin dans les bois dans les
bois papa bouin bois et enfin il est bon
ton 1
si tu le faisais sans faire attention tu
le ferais comment vas-y alors papa bois
dans l'épais pape à peine 1 des bois
dans les bois papa bois eux dans des
bois papa bois épais bon c'est bien tu
progresses je crois qu'ici on va
demander à sonia papa bois dans les pays
papa paix dans les bois dans les bois
papa bois épais voilà dans le 1 de sonia
on entend presque 1 g derrière pas pour
papa p papa bois dans les pins pas papin
dans les bois dans les bois papa bois
est pas voilà c'est parfait donc
maintenant et c'est d'être
tu vois aller coûte du son et de
corriger
voilà donc corriger la prononciation
fait c'est une prononciation si tu dis
ah c'est pas français
vous pour vous parler bien le français
quoi c'est pas parce que vous avez
l'accent que vous parlez moins bien le
français que quelqu'un qui vient de
tours de paris quoi je vous dis je vous
le dis jamais tu parles nous fait rire
valérie damaye et plus rigolo c'est pour
nous dire le par les marseillais c'est
une rigolade
c'est historique de rome s'est pas trop
me paraissait si je le perds pas ce
parce que le conservatoire parce que
voilà je rentre au conservatoire et que
je suis sur paris ou ailleurs et que je
le perds est-ce que ça fait un peu
bizarre parce qu'on a tellement
l'habitude d'entendre parler marseillais
que d'un coup tu parlerais ne sera un
peu plus pointu c'est sûr fait pas que
ça nous dérangerait mais bon ça nous
ferait bizarre mais dérangé alors
évident aujourd'hui comment vois tu es
mon vis du monde vit de beaux jours à
peine de le perdre mais c'est là où je
suis né c'est là où j'ai grandi et ça me
ferait peur quand même de le perdre aux
comores après si vous ça vous dérange
pas leur bon vous voyez bien monsieur
fernandel les marseillais eux mêmes
considèrent leur accent comme une blague
eh bien je voudrais alizée avec vous un
aspect particulier de l'accent
marseillais foutaise complot des
parisiens et si on allait ensemble poser
la question un chercheur spécialiste du
par les marseillais
par exemple très clair on peut dire tv
pour simplement inviter quelqu'un à
regarder quelque chose tv l'avion mais
on peut aussi allonger les syllabes du
ctv un peu qui viennent ce qui vous en
conviendrez produits incertaine effet
une double perception on va dire qu'à 15
un côté sympathique un côté ensoleillé
un côté chaleureux un côté sympa et
rigolo mais il ya aussi cette ambiguïté
parce que qui dit rigolo ça fait un peu
pas sérieux oui je sais monsieur
fernandel c'est moi qui exagèrent le
théâtre c'est un peu particulier mais
écoutez aussi romain lejeune
journalistes qui cherchent du travail
vocal au téléphoniste one et que je vois
0 et faut faire s'il reste dans la
maison que je prenne une voie qui passe
alors que cissé 046 16 04 vous pouvez
crier je n'ai pas mal au comment ça va
je m'en fous je vais faire quoi je vais
prendre des cours je gobain taxant pour
partir vivre sur paris et avait aucune
conviction et émeut dénaturaliser ce
serait bien pour toi que tu trouve un
boulot dans la région à ce n'est pas de
la région et à marseille parce que même
si tout banni sa relaxe en mars et ça
passe pas c'est gratuit
ils veulent pas de savoir si c'est ça le
deutschmobil sur 1,2 code c'est que
l'accent marseillais est limité à
marseille et
deux kilomètres à la ronde pas plus
simple les gens qui critiquent qui
sommes qu'on changeait de d'intonation
et de ses jardins ses pas réversible
dire que je gêne quand il a parlé avec
guy pas le reprendre l'avancé c'est pas
je ne connais pas je peux pas te dire
[Musique]
comment vit-on l'accent à l'autre bout
de la france
trouve-t-on le même paradoxe à
guignicourt petit village des vosges
je me suis d'abord arrêtés au lycée
agricole et ça tombe bien ce jour là des
futurs agriculteurs étudient la langue
de molière m jury filou vrai gibier de
potence
je n'ai jamais rien vu de si méchant que
ce maudit vieille et je pense sauf
correction qu'il a le job encore ce qui
permet de jouer ce sont les accents est
ce qu'il y avait des accents dans ce qui
vous a été présentée ici
nancy boy n'a pas de sens gaëtan reste
petit bois de l'accent alors est-ce que
l'accent tu reconnais pas d'accent est
ce que l'on est conscient mais j'en suis
conscient pour toi c'est quoi c'est une
fierté c'est un handicap dû faire dire
bien alors pourquoi c'est une fierté
c'est d'être vosgien enfin déjà fait
remarquer tabernacle soit prononcé alors
qu'ils sachent dans quelle condition
d'un stage en normandie
ouais non route a dit que toi tu étais
pas dans mon bain alors les essais et
comment t'as fait remarquer la chose
avec un jugement avec envie je suis pas
béat et parce qu'elles m'ont dit que ça
allait trop vite et
par m ça changera tout alors elle j'ai
aussi croisé la route de kevin l'adjoint
au maire comme les jeunes agriculteurs
il est fier de ses racines mais
contrairement à eux il n'a pas d'accent
et ça ça m'intéresse
alors pour nous en tant que vosgien ça
rappelle la terre voilà ça appelle le
travail manuel
ça rappelle vraiment nos racines c'est
pour ça qu'on est fiers par contre pour
les autres c'est vrai que c'est un peu
beauf isambert entre guillemets en
général quand on parle avec un accent
vosges et en se disant lui c'est un
beauf et et voire pire un consanguins
sur l'entente aussi en alsace
voilà bien sûr vous assurerez la son
trophée la mission elle à l'école en
ville du bonheur
alors tu penses que c'est pour ça qu'on
a moins strasbourg ils disent que j'ai
beaucoup je pense que demain on me force
à tu vas parler comme tout le monde
parce qu'il faut parler comme aux non
même si on qui pousse pas toi je sais
mais notre corps certains centres en
compte du coût toi tu te contentes pas
le même monde
côtoyer que de la paysannerie c'était
différent que quand tu côtoies là ça
change tout la grand mère de kévin
appartient elle à un monde en voie de
disparition
un monde cloisonné où l'on ne sortait
que rarement de son village ou de son
quartier
philippe boula de mareuil et chasseurs
d'accent toute l'année il parcourt la
france à la recherche de l'accent perdu
les zones rurales où les échanges sont
moins développées à l'intérieur des
grandes villes
on reste lent dans l'antre soit un
accent c'est une façon aussi de
renforcer la cohésion dans les groupes
alors que les métropoles brasse des
différences et aboutisse à un résultat
c'est la métaphore du melting-pot partir
d'une mosaïque initial on mélange le
tout et on aboutit à un résultat autre
ou beaucoup de différences sont
estompées mais d'où viennent les accents
pourquoi parle-t-on différemment dans
les bouges en alsace ou à marseille il y
à l'histoire d'abord si je vous avais
rencontrés au moyen-âge monsieur
fernandel nous ne serions pas compris
nous n'aurions pas parler la même langue
le saviez vous pendant des siècles les
français ne parlait pas français mais
breton alsacien provençal picard près de
400 langues patois ou dialectes
différents
la français et francophone entièrement
depuis peu en fait on estime que ça
remonte à la première guerre mondiale le
voir après les années 40 50 avec la
radio la télévision mais en fait on se
rend compte à la révolution par exemple
des enquêtes qui sont menées que
finalement et une poignée à 4,5 millions
si milan peut-être de francophones la
moitié qui parle parfaitement français
mais il leur est par autre chose le
français est une langue étrangère
pendant longtemps dans de nombreuses
régions
aujourd'hui encore comme en alsace des
français utilisent des langues
régionales pour communiquer ça sert à ça
ça à faire ça le fait de le savoir
ça doit pas de français et pas gras
comme ça nous l'a beaucoup moins haut là
un petit peu mais beaucoup donc par le
comique on connaît quoi c'est tout là
haut dit il
l'accent c'est un phénomène de contact
c'est à dire que c'est la transposition
le transfert de certaines
caractéristiques de l'orgue qui sont
parlées sur un territoire donné sur la
langue qui vient supplanter donc en
l'occurrence le français
[Musique]
un moment donné n'avait même plus de
droit à l'école de parler l'alsacien
on avait carrément des petites pièces
des petits médaillons et à 4 heures si
on avait ce médaillon la même punition
il fallait absolument parler le français
pour pertes et accent alsacien pas en
1882 avec jules ferry l'école devient
obligatoire et la langue française aussi
alors l'école a joué en retrait fort
parce que la plupart des gamins qui
arrivent et notamment dans les régions
rurales
ils arrivent à l'école avec une langue
qui était celle qu'on parlait à la
maison ou dans les champs au village qui
était alors ce qu'on appelait le patois
le la langue régionale
et puis on leur apprenait le français
donc une langue plus standardisés de
molière du manuel de grammaire etc
l école à corriger et à la corriger nos
demandes de manière assez violente
en tout cas symboliquement on est bien
connu qu'il était interdit de cracher de
parler breton dans les écoles de grande
bretagne par exemple aujourd'hui les
langues régionales telles que le breton
l'occitan l'alsacien sont
malheureusement pour le linguiste en
déclin et une trace a pu en être
conservées à travers des accents qui
préserve des spécificités de
prononciation
[Musique]
et vous vous parlez pas pas toi non
mais quelques mots quand je remonte chez
moi que je vais dans le nord j'aurais
tendance à employer des mots en patois
c'est malheureux d'avoir inventé par
avoir peur
d'abord il va je peux avoir deux jours
on avait tendance à dire que d'un
village à l'autre on parlait pas de la
même manière
ça ça a laissé beaucoup de traces dans
l'imaginaire commun
représentation une certaine inertie et
on continue à dire ça n'a pas le même
accent à 17 km de distance qui serait la
distance d'un relais de poste
aujourd'hui certaines langues comme le
picard ont quasiment disparu
tel un archéologue filippula de mareuil
on recherche les dernières traces double
but
ma venue c'est d'étudier la fois les
accents et leurs liens éventuels avec
les langues régionales
j'ai mené des enquêtes plus tôt dans le
sud en corse en roussillon
domaine occitan et là un des points de
de l'enquète a pour but d'enrichir un
atlas taux fondée sur l'inflation dans
différentes langues romanes et puis une
fois que tu seras rivage théia tu passe
à gauche et puis tu fais quelques pots
et puis à gauche y en a pas les à grand
palais avec plein de couleurs et puis
l'eau battu visite je palais et puis on
se donne rendez vous à 12 heures à
chaque cantine pour manger ensemble haut
partiront de l'eau entier notre main
event maroua me gave it est un cavité
profonde à 30 mètres trop chichement
mais je peux dormir jamais désiré si tu
as tout compris
je viens d'un milieu de prolos bon je
suis rentré des copains tout sa famille
le droit de pharmaciens ou médecin je me
surveillait quoi parce que voilà fallait
que je parle bien pu vous alliez honte
de notre acte en bas j'ai essayé de
gommer un petit peu voilà temps de faire
opérer en tant qu' on en tant que pro
un accent très vite se définit par
rapport à une norme un modèle de
référence li va être édictées de façon
plus ou moins arbitraires par par les
élites et donc vous fur et à mesure on
s'élève dans la hiérarchie sociale
on va trouver moins d'absents pour qui
accents faut qu'on soit 2 donc dire à
l'autre as tu as un accent c'est avoir
le pouvoir de dire moi j'ai quelque
chose qui est neutre n'auront mené ou en
tout cas passe partout
toi tu te distingue et de manière à la
fois positives et négatives mais en tout
cas tu es différent on compose une
différence par rapport à une norme c'est
un mécanisme de pouvoir
[Musique]
le
les actions du vieux port c'est celui-là
que j'ai en fait rire pour écrire marie
zoffany nettoyer récent des riches
bourgeois de la rue paradis et tu
connais bien qui font semblant de ne pas
avoir d' axa j'ai appelé noam ça avance
et qui parle un accent ainsi pense que
si on a un accent ne veut pas dire des
choses sensées ou intelligent nettoyer
donc en rue du coup l'album comme ça ils
pensent qu'ils sont intelligents parce
qu'ils ont pas d'accent moyenne oui
vraiment non vraiment on s'ennuie on a
une pression nous avaler quelque chose
de travailler hier je sais pas où que ce
soit au fond c'est quelque chose d après
tout ça et savary a peur et les
quartiers il faut dire aussi ça varie
avec classe sociale le peuple à l accent
beaucoup plus large
les patrons de bistrots le bel accent
car ému danser ça irait vite et pas dans
ses livres la mer il et toulonnais c'est
sa 95e théâtre parmi tant d'autres
c'est
laurent ya autre chose au 6 mai
alors arrêtez de jeunes encore p te la
mets toi je vois les budgets une façon
d'être
le marseillais s'est pas créé assez
les dates de paires de lunettes
les gens mettent sous l'accent un peu
tout et ils ont raison après tout
pourquoi pas c'est à dire qu'ils mettent
un peu de vocabulaire l'accent les
expressions le lexique et même une façon
d'être donc ses traits culturels en fait
l'accent dont il faut bien savoir ce
dont on parle est ce que les gens
veulent dire quand il parle de l'accent
au bord de la méditerranée là en tout
cas à marseille
toutes les phrases monde comme ça et
donc à une sonorité un petit peu comme
comme l'italie voyez ça ça fait cinq ans
jane accent chantant quoi parce que dieu
je suis allé à la maison et donc ça
montre tout le temps comme ça et c'est
vrai que c'est un phénomène de france
j'ai fait comme une chaîne sun donc moi
ça me plut pas évident parce que dans
mon quotidien je travaille avec des
jeunes en difficulté des quartiers et
cetera je peux pas leur dire
bon allez jamal tu vas étrangers non je
me suis battu wesh ces bombes ainsi
matringe et dépêche toi donc forcément
comme il ya un côté instinctif il ya le
côté ya le côté cagole marseillaise qui
ressort moi je n'ai ubi gelé perdu parce
que voilà j'étais à marseille jusqu'à 8
ans je l'avais et puis quand je suis
monté à paris j'ai dû le perdre
c'était une question de survie mais oui
à 8 ans c'est une question de survie
c'est à dire que tu es à l'école
primaire et que quand on se moque de toi
parce que tu as l'accent du sud eh bien
il faut que en une semaine quinze jours
tu règle le problème
il faut que je le perde ben voilà parce
que c'est quand même si on sait comme ça
mais bon franchement ça je te le dis ça
m'embête irait à la place de dire que je
le perde pas ce que c'est il ya une
notion de perte qui est terrible dans ce
que tu dis c'est à dire que je le
corrige et là on n'est plus dans cette
notion de la perte un moment précis qui
est le moment du du plateau le moment du
théâtre
c'est une règle une loi je crois que le
meilleur exemple c'est l'exemple du haut
c'est-à-dire quand vous dites la rose
jaune est bien là le eau de rose
c'est un offert mais ça il faut regarder
comment s'écrit le mot en phonétique
donc si tu dis la rose tu fais une
erreur
larose une erreur pour en avoir le coeur
net nous sommes allés avec romain au
laboratoire parole et langage ici une
centaine de scientifiques étudiait la
loupe
notre façon de parler d'une locutrice
est en fait elle c'est une personne qui
est pas du tout de la région est ce
qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va vous
enregistrez vous maintenant de la même
façon qu'elles pour regarder justement
qu'elles sont un peu les différences
qu'il peut y avoir entre soi façon de
sur les mêmes phrases je développe des
fonctions d'étiquetage je développe des
fonctionne dès du cottage pour les
petits déjeuners
je mange de la brioche pour le petit
déjeuner je mange de la brioche ou le
soir je vois là où les cheveux je
développe des fonctions d'étiquetage le
pari méridionale on a cette
particularité qui d'ailleurs la chose la
plus que l'on perçoit le plus facilement
c'est le fait qu'on prononce justement
ces phrases elles sont pas au hasard c
comprenant ce les muet alors justement
chez dans le méridional ils sont pas
mieux
je veux exactement pour le petit
déjeuner je mange de la brioche pour le
petit déjeuner je mange de la brioche
c'est la trace première au niveau
phonétique de l'âme et régionalisée tous
les soirs je me lave les cheveux tous
les soirs je me lave les cheveux cheveux
non je suis pas prêt de faire une pub
pour un championnat
et si l'accent était une question
d'oreille plutôt que de langue
marseillais entente il l'est même sens
qu'un picard ou un alsacien
sophie dufour une neuropsychologue a
mené une étude pertinentes sur le sujet
quelle poisse à toutes ces filles qu'il
faut bien l'avouer aux cheveux la même
chose
a priori l'expérience est facile romain
en temps des mots qui doit classés en
deux catégories d'un côté des mots
existants et de l'autre des mots
inventés siquet glaçons ratu bichot mais
le cobaye n'est pas au courant du
véritable but de l'expérience grâce aux
électrodes posées sur sa tête
sophie mesure au millième de seconde
près ces temps de réponse et sur
certains mots
romain est plus lent qu'un brut ont
acheté 424 qui nous intéresse c'est des
mots qui se termine on est et on est
donc dans des productions tu vas pas
dire hein tu les paies tous les bus
voilà donc on va voir comment est ce que
vous traitez ces mots en est en fête
et est ce que vous les distinguer dans
les tâches on venait dans une contrainte
de rapidité du colosse à 2,7 cette
différence entre ces fêtes de mauves qui
est un exemple est-ce que savoura entre
guillemets sont à certains ou certaines
fêtes de mots certains m'ont carrément
il existe un phénomène de surdité
phonologique ou et chez des auditeurs du
sud de la france
non monsieur fernandel on ne dit pas que
les méridionaux sont handicapés mais
votre oreille en temps certains sont
différemment de la mienne ou delà des
querelles de supporters de football
n'y at il pas un fossé infranchissable
entre un marseillais un parisien celui
du langage jus de lire ça chacun votre
tour dont la jeune naturellement en
crise aiguë en train de ligue 1 et si
vous deviez alors le dira parisienne
consoler bah oui c'est la prof a dit
bowman d'ajouter la parisienne vous fin
de contrat
vous me dire la parisienne
et oui mr le délégué c'est là que nous
qu'on me le dire sa part aisément
on craint dégun ah non mais même le mot
et non c'est pas possible on craint des
gants peut-être pas au travail mais à
l'école quand on me fait les l'aîné d
euros blanc pour les présentations de
projets etc
angie il faut pas trop que l'attitude
marseillaise la kz1 il faut un peu
calmer parce que ça fait pas trop
sérieux en tant que personne qui vient
d'une position sociale voilà je viens
d'une classes populaires les classes
moyennes etc je me vois mal être tout le
temps à assimiler à la fille migrer qu'
aucun effort d'intégration qui est
toujours rattaché à un langage qui est
faible alors que non et à la base si je
fais du théâtre c'est pour bien
justement bien apprendre à parler
puisque à la belgique commencé peut-être
puisque je faisais des études de fin de
droit et je voulais être avocate
il ya une discrimination mais qui est
qui est caché qui et j'allais dire
presque sournoise aussi parce que l'air
de rien on fait croire que ce sont des
petites remarque anodine alors que c'est
de la discrimination c'est une forme de
racisme de linguistique assez fort chez
certains et on le sent chez chez sonia
johan parfois c'est quelque chose
d'assez dur mais comme c'est dit
soutenant veloppe un peu légère c'est
dur de dire oui c'est du racisme en fait
dont je suis victime à bien vous savez
le je reçois pas 150 milles
scénario part par mois mais le plus que
je reçois des apajh de 3g une chemise à
fleurs à la page 2 4 se propose un
apéritif à tout le monde et à la page 2
5 une partie de pétanque
[Musique]
en alsace il existe une rivalité aussi
tenace que celle qui oppose les
marseillais au parisien entre les
vosgiens francophones et les alsaciens
germanophone le litige dure depuis
plusieurs siècles
donc dans un accent toi ça te revient
écoute début de l'année dans la classe
mais moi je le prends avec le sourire et
puis surtout je suis catalan je trouve
que ça affirme sa personnalité
et puis des fois il ya des accents ouais
un peu plus beau que d'autres mais
partout des gens de ma famille qui m'ont
dit que j'ai chopé la manière
kevin étudié en alsace depuis deux ans
et le vosgien de bonnes raisons de se
méfier
l'abus d'action peut être nuisible en
tout cas c'est ce qu'on enseigne dans
cette école de marketing
alors à vos questions dans un entretien
d'embauché comme enjeu pour en sortir
si ça n'arrivait pour pour kronenbourg
tout de suite monsieur m'a dit mais vous
n'êtes pas les haïtiens à vous ça va pas
coller est ce que ça peut vous sauver
stratégique de prendre l'accent de la
personne qui fait un entretien au stage
je pense que dans certaines situations
ça peut aider
d'abord l'accent les autres vous êtes
d'accord avec elle on va dire que quand
on va dans un entretien la personne on
la connaît pas du tout on sait pas qui
c'est on n'a aucun point commun avec
elle on ne sait pas comment l'aborder
mais voilà l accent alsacien où l'accent
du sud où n'importe quel accent et 11 i
bat ya en moi aussi j'ai cet accent vont
donc on a déjà un quelque chose de
convivial entre nous en fait et ça
détend un peu l'atmosphère
par contre moi je suis pas tout à fait
d'accord avec toi je pense que pour un
entretien avec quelqu'un qui a un fort
accent je pense qu'il faut rester très
neutre presque caché son accent en fait
sur le tour de table on l'avait un peu
près toute la situation possible de la
situation où effectivement cintreuse une
connivence et une proximité qui
contribue à relâcher un peu les défenses
et leur situation de négociation à
assouplir un peu les choses
avec le risque que ça passe pas quelque
chose de pas sincère voir un peu de la
manipulation et la personne en face du
coup ça pourrait faire l' inverse
pourrait se cabre et met donc trop mon
accent est ce qu'elle se moque de moi
est-ce que c'est difficile à déterminer
encore aujourd'hui la rivalité est
tenace entre kevin vosgien et ses amis
alsaciens
les clichés ont la vie dure est-ce que
vous trouvez que l'accent vosgien il est
différent l'accent alsacien
l'impression que je suis plus vosgien
qu'alsacien maintenant que je vis là en
alsace ils nous prennent pour des cons
et on veut pas le laisser au pas leurs
données résident non mais vous prend pas
plus cons voilà vraiment dépaysant mais
pas pour des cons non mais tout dépend
de ton discours pas forcément de ton
accent mois quand quelqu'un vient de
parler avec un accent alsacien 100% je
rigole ah non mais je ne peux pas le
prendre au sérieux
pourquoi c'est impossible à renard us ni
heureuse newey ça veut dire que peuvent
avoir ces quelqu'un va manger moi vous
me faire les choses et après quelqu'un
au niveau des repas myrtilles et retisse
un outil de gestion du grain d'aile
d'une toiture et et c'est comme ça la
myrtille ces jolies tu vois ça donne
envie de manger brimbelles tellement une
grand ben voilà et quand il va les
cueillir qui va pas là lundi avec une
ville un truc ça
une rifle et dans les relations
amoureuses
l'accent est il une maladie honteuse
j'ai plein d'amis dans les rues choquent
un accent assez compliquée et elle pour
trouver un ami en dehors des vosges
c'est très très compliqué c'est un
garçon qui rappelle le terroir bompas
est née fille qui parle vraiment comme
une bof là c'est dur et je pense que
c'est encore plus d'un comme une âme
pour une fille parce que là les
cataloguer comme une cabale qui parle
comme ça oui oui oui non c'est sûr que
pour une femme c'est plus agréable une
oeuvre 12 je pense que l'accent est fier
quand même plus adapté aux hommes si on
peut parler comme ça mais moi ça me
choque pas tant d'une fille surtout
quand elles sont jolies avec un accent
comme ça c'est pour le coup moi aussi
j'ai ce problème de dissonances quoi les
imagine elles sont très jolies et je
vois je les entends parler j'ai pas
léger pas le visuel devant et je me dis
merde là il ya ça va pas quoi moi alors
c'est paradoxal puisque j'ai l'axone
mais je me vois pas avec une fille qui
aime fera que sa mort c'est parce que là
c'est le couple de fada qui jouent à la
pétanque qui volent au pastis la femme
est pensionnaire le m'arrive travailler
sur le marché fait ça fait vraiment on
va dire le cliché quoi cet accent la
mistral signal et tambourin à toutes mes
chansons donnent un air refrain et quand
vous l'entendez chanter dans mes paroles
tous les mots que je dis dans ce
[Musique]
e
ce que je vais vous dire monsieur
fernandel ne va pas vous faire plaisir
à deux pas du vieux-port on peut
apprendre à parler point du crime de
lèse majesté au pays des santons
[Musique]
professeur de chant clémentine coppolani
propose des exercices de respiration et
de diction pour apprendre à maîtriser
son accent là tu as pris ton inspiration
vraiment tu bloques les airs et tu
cherches à les faire entrer un peu plus
tard pour qu'ils sont face à bong ici le
seul en tête pour qu'elles sont c'est sa
fin alors je peux prendre vos talents
oui
alors hop ça fait pour qui sont ces
serpents qui sifflent sur votre tête
vraiment certains du vent pour les
accentuations pour qui sont ces serpents
qui sifflent sur vos têtes
et ça aide aussi à tout simplement mieux
gérer l'air comme ça est d'apprendre à
prendre possession de l'appareil
respiratoire et de l'appareil phonatoire
et c'est vraiment arrivé à travailler
sur le contrôle de quelque chose qui
après deviendra naturel mais au début ça
ne l'est pas il faut quand même quelques
mois oui mais moi je suis plus d'un je
me dis j'ai envie d'y arriver direct
alors je sais que c'est pas possible pas
naturel pour l'instant en tout cas j'ai
craint d'entendre chantant dans un train
j'ai craint de t'entendre chantant dans
un train l'action il est quand même
maîtrisé
il est quand même maîtrisé quand tu le
souhaites sa part encore un certain
moment mais en tout cas aussi c'est un
pour un usage professionnel c'est quand
même maîtrisé je trouve un calife auchan
sur son canasson m bachimont
vous cache est un vieux bouc assima
l'onudc incidents insultes
je sais même pas si je le faisais je
suis un original qui ne se désole
finalisera jamais je suis un original
qui ne se désole finalisera jamais et
puis en plus cette phrase elle est
parfaite je suis pas un révolutionnaire
je pratiquais jacques padie dame en la
maintenant dans l'action dans le
journalisme la norme c'est tout ça que
ça marseillais à 16 heures tous au parti
s'approche de boules c'est pas du tout
mais vraiment pas du tout l'idée mais
c'est d'arriver à m'imposer avec eux ce
qui est pour moi une qualité à paris
romain retrouve mathias lucas et
benjamins ils ont tous fait la même
école de journalisme
mais eux ont trouvé du travail faut-il
garder son accent ou non le sujet
brûlant comme moi quand je dis je rigole
je la vois je branche le must de la
rédac rigolote georges la brèche et
l'attaqué rigoler et médias vous les
marseillais vous êtes banque a parlé tu
as jamais me disais mais dis moi j'ai
envie de lui dire mais lille et voulait
pas visibles à quoi vous êtes bon à quoi
en fait
non les bons à pâques à parler et avait
acheté les poissons sur le port si
j'étais que joue avec john wayne jouable
qui voit des pastis et toi t'es pas là
quoi alors la tomate et la tour eiffel à
te prendre le métro tous les jours alors
on est là mais c'est ça on est d'accord
ces salles on travaille sur des métiers
les uns comme les autres qui se veulent
ouverts sur le monde mais au final ils
entretiennent les clichés mais toi tu
veux te dit tu perds tu peine cinquante
mille euros par mois et tu me paies
relaxante tu vois pas le père d'axa mais
comment tu veux que je le perde mais tu
vas chez tu veux mais là c'est le court
il ya des cours d'eau contourne me va
mais tu me vois tu m'as vu
sur mes couilles à bien jouer c'est quoi
ce qui est menacé par des américains
déjà que je m'énerve pour rien que je
vais m'énerver je vais faire quoi je
monte dans les tours
je crois que je montre les tours en
parisien frère je vais c'est pas
possible en 6 nuls gros de dire un belge
jackson est déjà temps changent pas je
le fais pas avec gross et je te jure ces
risques je prend le problème à l'envers
c'est pas sa réponse et lui montrer que
le sujet le meilleur avec l'accent que
saint maxent et quoi qu'il en soit même
si on prend des cours même si on prend
des cours on parlera jamais comme un
parisien jamais quand même parisien
ferrat ça veut dire quoi première relaxe
ans n'avait pas dit au revoir à jamais
comme ça qu'on arrive tous les jours est
d'accord bon bah mais ça sera juste que
au lieu de dieu sait trop bien comment
ça va on dira jamais non plus mais brock
en parle entre nous on s'entend pas vous
avez honte et gâche toujours dit c'est
toi qui te bats sur toile axa star hier
guy parler non pas du tout mais pas du
tout on imagine que si on te demande de
te changer un peu ta façon à part les
crédits non oui je dis non a grossi
grave mais pourquoi ces graves comme
celles là donc demain tu diras tu as la
tête tu vas le faire soit 2 milliards et
déchargement mais ça sent constamment
changer durablement ces panneaux faits
sur ces du verbal du verbe à la pause on
parle juste de l'emportement ma faveur
toulouse ap les sabres c'est ce n'est
pas la même chose la tour harmonie
romain serait-il un vrai fada pourquoi
s'acharne t il à vouloir travailler dans
un monde qui ne veut pas de lui
si vous reveniez sur terre monsieur
fernandel ou n'en croiriez pas vos
oreilles
il n'ya pas d'accent sur le petit écran
ou à la radio
toutes les boissons et même comme la
mienne à quelques exceptions près
[Musique]
dans l'application de ce plan carlos
tavares on vous reproche parfois d'avoir
sacrifié les dépenses dans le secteur de
la recherche
pour garantir la reconstruction
économique de l'entreprise et nous reste
maintenant aller chercher ce troisième
objectif mais il ya une accélération
donné raison à ceux qui critiquent le
choix du gouvernement on avait peut-être
pas besoin les entreprises la vôtre n'a
peut-être pas besoin
voilà d'accord je vous trouve renseigner
et vous avez toujours été pour moi du
moins ma génération la référence en
matière d'action et de réussite dans le
journalisme et je voulais savoir quel a
été le déclic pour voir quel monde vous
avez su en faire une force
j'ai démarré dans la vie professionnelle
je l' ai dit tout à l'heure mais par la
presse écrite est donc là l'accent
n'avait aucune importance et j'ai fait
de l'audiovisuel après j'aurai inverser
les choses à faire ou du moins j'aurai
commencé par l'audiovisuel sans doute
toujours été confronté va sans doute
peut-être j'aurais été confronté à
d'autres demandes jeu je ne sais pas
exactement
donc je peux pas dire que j'en ai
souffert mais j'ai pris conscience que
ça pouvait être un problème parce que
j'ai reçu des courriers à un moment de
gens c'est un point de vue insupportable
et raciste qui m'écrivait mais avec
votre accent vous osez parler de
politique
on nous enfermez vous et moi dans des
catégories particulières franchement
faire du journalisme audiovisuel avec un
accent pareil c'est quand même gonflé et
si malgré tout vous persistez 2 mais
vous faites voilà soit vous présenter la
météo quoi en gros voilà et au présenter
la météo le sous-entendu c'est avec
votre accent vous ne pouvez annoncer que
du soleil si con puisqu'on méga le
consistoire
est-ce que vous pensez que je dois quand
même un accent au profit de ma carrière
où je dois rester celui que je suis
c'est une question très difficile
le risque que vous perdiez la
possibilité d'être embauché si vous ne
modifiez pas quelque chose chez vous et
grands on ne peut pas vous conseiller de
vous entêtez monju j'ai connu des
journalistes qui au fond mettez dans
votre situation
les journalistes qui commençaient leur
carrière et qui ont modifié leur façon
de parler que j'ai d'énormes en tête qui
ont modifié leur façon de parler parce
qu'ils voulaient
intégrer une rédaction mais c'est une
cruauté incroyable cette histoire vous
vous trouvez que j'ai l'accent vous
c'est certain sincèrement oui parce que
moi vous l'entendez pas oui là dessus
voilà mes paroles oui appris que quand
mon amour de rage ou à l'école ça je
vous écoutiez c'est vrai que des fois
j'en rigolais mais je trouve pas non
mais ce qui est formidable
après si demain votre parcours vous
amène à travailler dans un média
national et à votre accent est un atout
formidable
[Musique]
et si quand on dit à romain tu es de
marseille on voulait surtout lui dire tu
n'es pas de paris tu n'es pas de notre
monde
mais qui se cache derrière le conte moi
vous le pouvoir ici le problème était
politique
comment l'accent raisonne-t-il dans les
couloirs de l'assemblée nationale
des gens
cbg fait français troisième langue parce
que papa avait voulu que je prends
d'abord le béarnais bien suite quand
j'étais avec des petits bergers espagnol
à la frontière mais sur territoire
espagnol papa était berger cet endroit
là au lac d'estaing ce que j'avais
appris avec eux l'espagnol crainte de
france est considéré que c'était une
chose trop sérieuse pour qu'on la prenne
à n'importe comment ils pensaient que
c'était des professionnels qui donnent
la preuve il a donc entendu que 1 ce
soit des soeurs noires de la république
qui ça n'occupe à l'âge de 6 ans c'est
de là qu'est venu mon avis ça et je ne
suis jamais à vrai dire poser de
question à savoir si c'était bon ou pas
et je dois dire que cela m'a plutôt pas
mal réussi
alors là l'observation sur l'accent ces
liens de certains journalistes avec
certains journalistes systématiquement
ont une forme de moquerie une forme de
dérision mais moi ça me dérange ça me
dérange absolument pas l'axé angers en
fait et j'en suis fier c'est l'accent
des cités ouvrières dans la bande de
clermont ferrand ça se rapproche de
l'accent de fernand raynaud
on ne joue pas sur l'autre acteur
lorsqu'on on peut faire d'ailleurs pour
est-ce qu'on pourrait accentuer notre
axe a peut-être un peu toujours quand
même un peu mieux sur le personnage de
la limite peut-être qu'aujourd'hui ce
n'est pas le bassin rennais le vernis
l'occitane et de bretagne le corps ce
qui met le français en danger
ça a pu être le cas il ya deux cents ans
un moment la république s'établissent et
aujourd'hui c'est nous mêmes sur le
président parce que malheureusement je
me demande si nous avons vraiment choisi
de défendre le français ont adopté cette
langue sans mémoire ni rêve quel angle
au dollar voilà le fil que l'on a entre
nous
en 1978
c'est la première fois où j'entrais à
l'assemblée nationale est un peu par
dérision dans l'entourage de valérie
giscard d'estaing une personnalité un
peu influente nous regardé avec
étonnement d'abord parce que nous
n'avions pas c'était prévu pour arriver
à l'assemblée nationale deuxièmement
parce que nous avions un peu l'accent et
cette personnalité disait ah ah ah voilà
les députés pizzaïolo ceux qui feront la
pizza bon ça ça m'avait plutôt un peu
blessé même si j'ai beaucoup d'amitié
pour ceux qui font la pizza et surtout
la mode
ce déficit a été ramené de vie vous le
savez bien monsieur fernandel accent on
s'en sert aussi à parier arlette
carlotti en scéne ministre a été raillée
parce qu'elle en a joué écoutez sa façon
de parler à l'assemblée nationale elle
n'a pas d'accent progression de l'ondam
médico social consacré à l'accueil des
personnes handicapées et elles ont
besoin elles aussi en revanche invité
dans cette émission de télévision son
accent est prononcé on en a assez de
l'image qu'ont montré puis au quotidien
les marseillais sont moins heureux on
veut pas le dire quand on est à paris
et quand on est à marseille on dit on
aime notre ville mais il ya des moments
où on aime moins qu'avant dans le
quotidien ont même pas moqué parce que
j'avais trop l'accent mais on a laissé
entendre que je voulais le camoufler je
veux pas être camouflée voilà je suis
comme ça je parle comme je parle je suis
comme je suis et quand j'étais en face
akhenaton vous savez de quoi on parle et
on parle et marseille ce qu'il faut
réconcilier marseille avec les
marseillais les quartiers nord avec les
quartiers sud
je ne cache pas mon accent pour cacher
mon accent j'ai l'habitude de quand je
parle de dossiers d'avoir un accent plus
neutres peut-être que c'est mon
éducation qui a fait ça vous avez décidé
de lutter contre le non recours au tour
droite qui rend nos politiques
inopérante toute la haute administration
les cadres supérieurs des entreprises
ils ont une neutralité d'accent il parle
presque tous la même langue
parce qu'ils sont formatés pour ça et
c'est pour ça qu'il ya des difficultés
quand vous portez fortement votre accès
il ya des difficultés d'existence de
prise au sérieux deux prises en compte
je vais vous faire une confidence quand
on a l'accent marseillais
on s'attend plus à ce que vous soyez un
comique qu'une ministre
je souhaite que le spectacle de noël et
n'a toujours présente et pourtant il
n'ya pas si longtemps le président de la
république présentait ses voeux aux
français avec un accent de haute garonne
en roulant les r
le r prononcé avec la pointe de la
langue organes érectile est associé à
une idée de
virilité c'était la prononciation
du roi est également le r roulés étaient
la prononciation des paysans qui
travaillait dur la terre en plein air
aujourd'hui le r roulés qui symbolisait
une france rurale a quasiment disparu
mais pourrait-on encore imaginer un
président de la république avec l'accent
avoir un accent c'est ne pas être
légitime légitime c'est celui qui est si
possible neutre ou en tout cas qui est
proche de ses figures de pouvoir donc le
président ne peut pas et ça peut changer
puisque les américains ont bien élu un
président noir qui l'aurait cru dans les
années 60-70 donc peut-être dans
quelques années on aura un président
marseillais veulent accents mars qui
[Musique]
mais qui décide de la bonne
prononciation du bon accent l'académie
française le lieu sacré du bon parler
français et comme on dit qu'il ya un
français canonique
c'est un peu le temple du de la langue
française vous pourrez lire ça c'est non
effectivement c voilà c'est une fois de
plus c'est ce que disait maurice druon
voilà on enregistre lusage mais on
rectifie aussi si les fautifs voilà
parce que on peut pas non plus accepter
une forme de laisser aller qui qui
ferait qu il suffirait qu'une chose a
été dit une fois pour que pour qu'elle
soit considérée comme recevable au même
titre que ce qui est sanctionné par les
siècles d'usagé l'académie très
clairement créé pour servir le roi de
france dans les statuts de l'académie
c'est nous allons embellir et rendre pur
cette langue que vous portez avec vos
armes dans tous les coins du monde
en gros et vous l'imposer aux peuples
conquis
pourquoi parce que c'est une langue
supérieur donc les gens ne te considère
que le français est de fait la langue
universelle parce que la france avait la
plus puissante armée et avait un empire
qui était plus puissant que les autres
au tournant de la révolution si on veut
être français si on veut être si on
faire partie de cette nation éclairée
moderne la patrie des droits de l'homme
qu'il faut parler français il n'y a plus
le choix
à la fin du xviiie siècle
on va donc créer ce dictionnaire de
l'académie qui va devenir pour beaucoup
la norme de référence l'académie
régenter au sens politique du terme les
usages et de concessions alors il ya
deux deux ouvrages principaux vous avez
celui-ci de l'est ont rarement il ya des
prononciations canonique y sont
répertoriées par la plupart des la
plupart des dictionnaires de langue avec
l'éventuel manque quelques variantes par
exemple pour bouffonne y signale que le
muet on ne fait pas généralement on ne
fait pas entendre un des points sur
lesquels s'accordent la plupart des
déchirant qui qui étudie les accents
c'est qu'on considère que le bon accent
c'est celui qui se fait pas remarquer
voilà c'est celui qui est le plus neutre
possible
c'est pour ça que à côté donc de de
paris qui est comment dire
pour le le le qui est le lieu un des
lieux du bois d'accent sans doute pour
des raisons
socio-économique presque il ya une
deuxième région qui a été longtemps
présenté comme étant l'endroit où on
parlait le meilleur français c'est les
bords de loire où la région d'angers
tour mon enquête se termine là en
touraine je sens que vous tremblez
monsieur fernandez au 19e siècle le
poète alfred de vigny définissent et
ainsi les habitants des bords de loire
leur langage et le plus pur le berceau
de la langue elle a une réputation
encore apprécier aujourd'hui par les
étrangers qui veulent apprendre notre
langue
alors le français garanti pur sans
accent fantasme ou réalité
c'est vrai qu'il ya une norme de
prononciation et probablement que dans
la région du val de loire
on est proche de cette norme voilà mais
dans une population qui aujourd'hui est
beaucoup plus brasser qu'autrefois
ce n'est pas à tour il n'y a pas que des
tourangeaux d'accord les gens mobilité
beaucoup plus important de contre froid
quand je pense que cette notion de
d'action de de caractérisation
régionales c'est peut-être moins
prégnant qu autrefois sonia la
colombienne norap et la thaïlandaise et
anna l'équatorienne sont venus de très
loin pour apprendre à parler le bon
français
nicole leur hôtesse prêche la bonne
parole
ou plutôt le bon accent mais on n'aime
pas les
la capitale tu es dans une région qui
est réputé part qu'il n'ya pas d'accent
c'est la région semble-t-il on parle le
meilleur français
mais c'est si charmant les accents ces
charmants mais quand tu apprends une
langue je pense qu'il faut apprendre ça
dans une région où c'est le plus pur
quand même oui c'est plus facile
après tu peux adapter bon c'est un mythe
à la lutte la pureté me qu'on retrouve
dans beaucoup de langues l'arabe pur le
catalan pur le turc pur de l'époque de
mustafa kemal donc et toujours cette
idée de pureté qui en fait une façon
d'asseoir un pouvoir encore une fois de
dire là quelque chose que l'on n'a que
vous n'avez pas pourquoi la touraine
c'était le château le tour est l'un des
berceaux d'aider des rois de france donc
c'est une région qui est aussi central
centralisée avec peu de contacts
linguistique donc qui a effectivement
moins d'interférence je dirais de
contact de langues
après c'est un mythe comment comme un
autre vous voyez monsieur fernandel
toute cette histoire n'est qu'une
légende après tout notre accent c'est
votre carte d'identité le mien il est de
partout il est de nulle part
alors gardez le vôtre très fort mais en
même temps mon accent a permis d'avoir
une visibilité en tout cas d'avoir une
batterie densifier quoi je peux vous
donner le rendez-vous mais
j'aurai un accent plus fort avec le
temps c'est logique
j'ai l'impression de me forcer comme je
parle sans accent je vais essayer de le
garder quand même oui vous prennent
comme ça commente à l'égout vos gentils
robin mais ce n'est pas naturel ou noyés
quand je crois comme ça elle se dit mais
qu'est ce qui fait le jeune homme qu'est
ce qui fait alors que quand je parle
comme ça ça va de suite mieux avec ma
bouée avec mon personnage c'est c'est
mieux c'est de suite mieux
le langage qui est aux normes il
transforme
moi je dis pas seulement un peu une
cagole mais depuis ma de rang
face même ligne de la france
d'aussi loin que je me souvienne il
s'appelle pas là
vienne le monde
[Musique]
maman
même chez les parisiens
on a
ça des fois et fait voler
mais on a
c'est ma cave denis
dix listes et un jour dit tout
hollande
[Musique]
mais chez nous
assad
il fait les volets
mais
ça c'est ma carte d'identité et puis
c'est tout